ah
de cara al inicio de la estación estival
italia reduce significativamente las
restricciones ligadas a la pandemia de
coronavirus a partir del próximo lunes
28 de junio se pone fin a la obligación
de utilizar mascarilla al aire libre una
decisión adoptada con el visto bueno del
comité científico que asesora el
gobierno italiano desde el inicio de la
pandemia en las últimas semanas las
hospitalizaciones y los contagios por
kobe han ido disminuyendo paulatinamente
los nuevos contagios están a niveles
comparables con los del pasado mes de
septiembre y paralelamente la campaña de
vacunación avanza un total del 30 por
ciento de la población de más de 12 años
ha sido ya vacunadas es decir casi 16
millones de personas y más de 46
millones de dosis individuales de la
vacuna han sido administradas aquí en
italia
[Música]
gracias a las buenas cifras de la
pandemia francia sigue levantando las
restricciones que ha impuesto desde hace
más de un año contra el kobe 19 este
verano serán las discotecas las que por
fin vuelvan a recibir público estos
establecimientos que han estado cerrados
por más de 15 meses pues podrán acoger
público a partir del 9 de julio pero con
algunas restricciones un aforo de máximo
al 75% en sala y sobre todo cada cliente
tendrá que mostrar un pase sanitario en
donde esté ya sea una prueba de
vacunación completa o un resultado de
menos de 48 horas de un test de kobe
durante este verano precisamente cuando
las autoridades sanitarias estarán muy
al tanto de lo que suceda en todo el
país y han previsto distribuir
masivamente el test casero de kobe de
entre los turistas y por último se
espera esa fecha del primero de julio
que será digamos el gran boom de el
turismo cuando entra en vigor en toda la
unión europea el pasaporte sanitario que
permita a los millones de habitantes del
bloque poder viajar entre los diferentes
países sin restricciones sin necesidad
de cuarentena simplemente mostrando este
pasaporte en el que estará la prueba de
una vacunación completa
reciente de un test de comida
[Música]
este sábado la mascarilla ya no será
obligatoria en exteriores en españa' una
norma que se flexibiliza tras un año de
aplicación otras medidas se relajan por
ejemplo las discotecas vuelven a abrir
hasta las 3 de la mañana en barcelona y
en madrid y otra cosa ya no hay toques
de queda desde hace un mes
si españa relaja sus restricciones es
porque la vacunación avanza el 50 por
ciento de la población y ha recibido a
lo menos una dosis españa también lo
hace para atraer a los turistas desde el
7 de junio todos los turistas
extranjeros internacionales que estén
vacunados pueden volver aquí es
imprescindible que vuelvan ya que el
turismo representa el 13 por ciento de
los ingresos anuales españoles por eso
españa fue uno de los primeros países a
pedir a la unión europea un certificado
digital sanitario un certificado que
funcionara a partir del primer de julio
[Música]